Hi everyone, I'm
Dr. Adina Leder, and
today I'm talking
about spinal cord
syndromes and common
mononeuropathies.
So the session
objectives for today
include describing the
ascending and descending
spinal cord tracks,
I will explain
the common spinal
cord syndromes based
on cord location, will
generate a differential
diagnosis based
on the location of
the spinal cord
injury, will apply the
proper workup for a
spinal cord lesion,
and recognize a
neurosurgical emergency.
So just to review
some cord anatomy,
the spinal cord
generally ends around L1.
There's central gray
matter, which contains
the neuronal cell
bodies and synapses, and
peripheral white
matter, which contains
the ascending and
descending fiber pathways.
Just to clarify, this is
opposite from the brain.
The gray in the
brain is outside,
while the white
is inside.
In terms of the ascending
tracts, the posterior
columns include the
gracili fasciculus,
which supplies the
lower body, the cunate
fasciculus, the upper
body. and the posterior
columns mediate fine
touch, vibration, and
proprioception, and
it crosses over in the
brainstem. It explains
where you are in space.
Spinoflammic tracts
are for crude
touch, pain, and
temperature and crossover
after ascending
one or two levels.
In terms of
descending tracts,
the corticospinal
tract begins
in the primary
motor cortex,
and the primary
motor cortex in the
precentral gyrus goes
to the anterior horn,
and this is what's
considered a long tract.
At the level of
the medulla, the
majority cross
over and become
the lateral
corticospinal tracts.
myelopathy or spinal
cord injury causes
gait disturbance
spasticity weakness
hyperreflexia bowel
or bladder symptoms
and a sensory
level which is that
band-like sensation
at the superior margin
of the level
there is generally
numbness and paresthesia
below the level
There are different
types of spinal cord
lesions. There is
central lesion,
which is often a syrinx
or syringomyelia,
posterior column
syndrome, which
can present as
tevis dorsalis,
anterior cord
syndrome, which can
occur from an
anterior spinal artery
infarct. There's
cortoquina syndrome,
posterior lateral
column syndrome,
or subacute combined
degeneration,
a complete transection,
and a Brown-Cicard.
The etiologies include
vascular, infectious,
traumatic,
autoimmune,
metabolic, toxic,
nutritional,
inflammatory, neoplastic,
and structural.
So the first case is a
30-year-old, otherwise
healthy woman who
presents to an outpatient
clinic complaining
of loss of pain and
temperature in a cape
-like distribution.
Sensory and
motor are also
affected in the hands.
And to the right,
the picture
shows the distribution
of where there
is pain and
temperature loss.
This is what's called
the central cord
syndrome. It affects
the gray matter in the
center of the cord,
and the causes include
trauma, which could
be a severe cervical
hyperextension,
intramedullary tumor,
a syrinx, which
is like a cyst
within the cord,
and the patient may
also have a Chiari
malformation.
There could be small
hemorrhages or a
demyelinating lesion
within the spinal cord.
a central cord or
syrinx lesion is a csf
containing cord cavity
the cervical region
is most commonly
affected it's rarely
in the thoracic cord
alone and it can be
seen in 20 to 40
percent of chiari 1
malformations and to
the left is an image of
a chiari malformation
where you can see
that the brain is
being pushed down into
the foramen magnum,
so they're low-lying
cerebellar tonsils,
and then there is also
an associated syrinx
with this lesion.
Syringomyelia, the
cord damage begins
centrally, and it
spreads outward.
Spinal thalamic
fibers are damaged
initially, and there's
loss of pain and
temperature in a cape
-like distribution. Case
2 is an 80-year-old
man who presents
with difficulty
walking. He states that
he's fallen while in
the shower, especially
he closes his eyes
to wash his hair.
And this is a dorsal
column disorder. You
could see the spinal
cord and the section
posteriorly is
what's affected here.
So dorsal column
syndrome is impairment
of vibration and
proprioceptive sense.
They present with
a stomping gait.
Lermit's sign,
which is an electric
shock that runs down the
back, is elicited
by neck flexion.
And dorsal root
involvement involves
absent reflexes
in the knees
and ankles with
preserved strength.
There is loss of
joint sensation
with associated
repeated microtrauma
and Charcot's
arthropathy.
The causes of dorsal
column syndrome
include Tabeus
dorsalis, which
is syphilitic
spinal cord disease,
cervical spondylosis,
posterior spinal
artery infarction,
multiple sclerosis,
partial cord
trauma, or post
-platinum-based
chemotherapy agents.
And to the side is
an examiner testing
proprioceptive
sense in a patient.
You hold the toe on
either side of the
toe, and the patient
closes their eyes, and
the toe is moved up
and down, and the
patient is asked where
the toe is in space.
And loss of
proprioceptive sense is
seen in a dorsal
column syndrome.
in tabes dorsalis which
is neurosyphilis it
is caused by a spirochete
it occurs decades
after the primary
infection most commonly
it could be after
20 years there are
progressive gait
abnormalities including a
slapping gait and a
positive romberg which is
swaying with the eyes
closed and to the right
is a picture of a
patient they should
have their feet together
though the patient
should be able to stand
steady, eyes open,
with their feet
together. They then close
their eyes. If they
start swaying when their
eyes are closed, it's
a positive Romberg.
And this, again,
occurs with
a posterior
column syndrome.
The symptoms of
tabes dursalis or
neurosyphilis are a
triad of symptoms. There
are lightening or
lancinating pains,
ataxia, which
is poor balance,
and bowel and
bladder dysfunction.
The signs include
Argyle Robertson
pupils, so the
pupils react to
accommodation
but not to light.
So if a patient is
asked to look at
something that's very
small and close to
them, the pupils
will get smaller,
but if you shine a
light in the pupils,
they don't get
smaller, and that's
what's called an
Argyle-Robertson pupil.
Areflexia means loss
of reflexes, and they
also have associated
loss of proprioception.
And this is an image
of a Lermit sign, which
is when the patient's
neck is flexed
forward, they feel a
vibration or sometimes
people will describe
it feels like a cell
phone is vibrating in
their pocket going from
the top of their neck
all the way down.
Case 3 is a 58-year
-old woman who underwent
bariatric surgery
several months
ago. She was non
-compliant in following up
with her surgeon.
Today, she presents
with numbness and
weakness of her feet.
And this is a
posterolateral column. There
is involvement of posterior
column and lateral
corticospinal tracts,
also called subacute
combined degeneration,
and the symptoms
include numbness, a
positive Romberg sign,
glossitis, which is
inflammation
of the tongue,
pernicious anemia,
vibration, and
position sense lost.
And the causes of
subacute combined
degeneration include
B12 deficiency
and copper
deficiency, which can
both occur with
bariatric surgery,
cervical spondylosis,
HGLV-1-associated
myelopathy or tropical
******* periparesis,
AIDS-associated
myelopathy, nitrous
oxide exposure, or ******
use, which is either
by IV or inhalation.
And some causes
of B12 deficiency
include bariatric
surgery,
atrophic gastritis,
celiac disease,
pancreatic
disease, a
vegetarian diet,
antacid use,
nitrous oxide
toxicity, or *****, and
infections including
H. pylori, giardia,
HIV, and D. ladle.
So nitrous oxide
can be seen
commonly. It's
a laughing gas,
colorless and odorless,
and the reason
that it causes a
subacute combined
degeneration is
because it causes an
irreversible inactivation
of B12. It's used
recreationally
for mood-elevating
properties, and a
toxicity can occur after
several uses or after
a single exposure.
And what can happen is a
myelopathy,
cognitive issues,
neuropathy, very
often there's numbness
in the feet and
weakness and generally
posterior and lateral
columns of the
cervical and thoracic
cord can be affected.
But it's very important
if you suspect
nitrous oxide
***** that you get
the full history
because if the patient
doesn't volunteer
this, then it's
possible that this
can be overlooked.
Case 4 is a 73-year
-old man with an
abdominal aortic
aneurysm rupture.
He had surgical repair
of the aorta, and
then the next morning
he was unable to
move his legs.
There was a flaccid
paraplegia, a sensory
level at T9 to T10,
and there was numbness
below the level.
so this is an
anterior cord syndrome
where there is
associated weakness and
numbness but the
proprioception is spared
so as you can see
from this diagram
the blue arrow is
pointing towards the
front of the cord
and this is showing
the region of the
anterior cord syndrome,
with the dorsal
columns being spared.
So what is the most
common cause of a
spinal cord infarction?
And while all of
these can cause spinal
cord infarction,
atherosclerosis of the
aorta is the most common.
In terms of the
clinical pattern
of an anterior
cord lesion,
there is weakness
below the level
There's loss of
pain and temperature
sensation below the
level of the lesion.
Autonomic function
loss below the level.
Vibration and position
sensation are spared.
This is most
suggestive of an
anterior spinal
artery infarct.
Case 5 is a 68-year
-old man who presents
to the emergency
room with severe low
back pain and radiation
into bilateral
posterolateral
legs, the right more
than the left. He
admits to weakness in
the legs. there's
been difficulty with
urination for the
past few days, and
he's unable to feel
when he's urinating.
This is a cauda
equina syndrome.
Cauda equina
is a collection
of nerve groups
from L2 to L5,
S1 to S5,
coccygeal segments,
the lower limb
movement, L2 to S2,
lower limb
sensation, L2 to S3,
bladder control,
S2 to S4,
control of external
**** sphincter, S2
to S4, and perennial
sensation, S2 to S4.
The causes of a
cauda equina syndrome
can be attributed to
the intervertebral
discreniation, which is
the most common cause.
It can also be due
to spinal fracture,
iatrogenic causes,
or a tumor.
Clinical features of
quadroquina syndrome
include low back pain
and radicular symptoms,
which is a very
common complaint
in any clinic,
bladder symptoms,
which must be
asked about,
bowel symptoms,
which occur less than
urinary symptoms,
but can be associated
with constipation
and ****** fullness,
****** dysfunction,
sensory loss, including
in the buttocks,
posterior thighs,
perineal region,
and this has to be
questioned, whether
the patient has these
symptoms. Weakness
is asymmetric,
and reflexes are
reduced at the knees
and at the ankles.
In order to assess
and manage cardioquina
syndrome, MRI
is the imaging
modality of choice.
Treatment is surgical
decompression. It
generally occurs
only in 1 to 2
percent of cases.
This is a 49-year-old
man who presents to
the emergency room
after a bar fight. It
resulted in a knife to
a spine on the right
side. On examination,
there's weakness on
the right with loss of
pain and temperature
on the left below the
level of the lesion.
This is what's called a
Brown-Saccard syndrome.
It's a hemicord
injury which disrupts
descending already
crossed corticospinal
fibers. There is
segmental muscle
weakness and atrophy
and sensory signs.
In this syndrome is
ipsilateral motor
weakness, ipsilateral
vibratory and
proprioceptive loss,
and contralateral
pain and temperature
loss below the
lesion. And these
are often incomplete.
In a hemicord
lesion, what type of
lesion is most
likely responsible?
intramedullary,
extramedullary,
or hematogenous spread.
So it's most common to
have an extramedullary
lesion, which means
it's coming in from
the outside, whether
it's a tumor or trauma.
And the causes of
hemicord syndrome are
more commonly
penetrating trauma or
a stab wound. It
could be a lesion from
multiple sclerosis,
a spinal subdural
hematoma, an
asymmetric compression,
an inflammatory
infectious lesion such as
neurosarcoidosis, a
neoplasm, primary or
metastatic, or a
spinal cord herniation.
K7 is a 16-year
-old man who is
brought to the
hospital after
doing a trick
on his bicycle.
When he landed, he
fractured his cervical
spine at the level
of C7 below the
phrenic nerve. The
spinal cord was crushed.
As a result, he
developed paralysis
below C7 with associated
loss of sensation
and loss of autonomics
to the extent
that he was unable
to have a bowel
movement without *****
and disimpaction.
This is what's called
a complete transection
of the cord. It can
be due to trauma such
as a stab wound,
demyelinating disease,
spinal cord
vascular disorders,
epidural abscess
or metastasis,
paraneoplastic
necrotizing myelopathy,
late radiation
-induced myelopathy,
or a herniated
intervertebral disc.
With a complete transection,
there's bilateral
upper motor neuron
pattern weakness below
the level of the lesion,
bilateral sensation
loss below the level
of the lesion, and
autonomic function
loss below the level,
with constipation being
most commonly seen.
Infectious
myelopathies can also
cause dysfunction
to the spinal cord
and can be caused
by viral bacterial,
parasitic, and
fungal infections.
And here are some
of the viruses
that can cause
myelopathy.
And you don't need
to memorize all of
these, but just understand
that all of these
different viruses
can cause myelopathy.
It should also be
known that acute COVID
-19 infection can cause
spinal cord symptoms
as well as a neurologic
complication.
This is a review of
the cord lesions, and
you can see here a
diagram of where in the
cord, it is affected,
and then you can pair
it with symptoms that
go along with it.
In terms of
mononeuropathies,
median neuropathy, ulnar
neuropathy,
radial neuropathy,
fibular or peroneal,
and then lateral
femoral cutaneous
nerve are the most
common mononeuropathies
that we see.
Median neuropathy
is also known as
carpal tunnel syndrome.
It's extremely
common. It doesn't
just have to be
seen in people who
are typing. There
is wrist pain with
hand numbness,
associated sensory loss
in the palmar aspect
of the first three
to four digits with
thenar weakness that
occurs late in the
course of the condition.
Very often, patients
complain that this
wakes them up in the
middle of the night
while they're sleeping.
In ulnar neuropathy,
it's generally caused
by something that's
such as trauma at
the elbow. There's
numbness in half of
the fourth digit and
in the fifth digit,
clawing of the
fourth and fifth
digit, and weakness
in wasting of the
first dorsal
interosseous muscle.
There is
generally repeated
elbow trauma, and
you could also
have finger
adductor weakness.
a radial neuropathy
can cause unilateral
painless wrist drop
there is finger or
wrist extension weakness
generally painless
gradually progressive
bilateral wrist drop
can also be due to
lead poisoning and
can occur due to an
alcoholic with saturday
night palsy the spiral
groove is generally
the localization
for this neuropathy.
A fibular or peroneal
neuropathy is the
most frequent
mononeuropathy in the lower
extremity. There's
weakness of ankle
dorsiflexion and a foot
drop can also be seen.
Trauma is the
most common cause
of the fibular
head and it may
be seen with
recent weight loss.
Then there's also
Muralgia parasthetica,
which is commonly seen
due to compression
of the lateral femoral
cutaneous nerve where
it crosses under the
inguinal ligament.
It is generally when
patient either has
gained weight, it can
be due to pregnancy
or pelvic surgery,
and there's
numbness and sometimes
pain of the lateral
thigh. It can also
be seen in police
officers who are
carrying a gun with a
holster that are
pushing on that nerve.
So in summary,
it's important to
recognize spinal
cord syndromes
based on clinical
presentations.
The students
are expected to
apply proper workup
and recognize
neurosurgical
emergencies.
Thank you.